[Music]
imagine having to pay back a loan you
didn't even take out because
you got scammed that happens to a lot of
people
right and then the bank is like too bad
you gotta pay what kind of bank does
that when they're like
it's not even me that did it yeah
there's bank in russia
oh that's russia a russian bank so so
this man this russian man
he got his smart her smartphone stolen
and i'm very smart well my phone was
smart
not him oh even though it's not his
fault because it was stolen but
okay exactly so his phone was stolen
and he had that bank mobile app
in his phone and so these the the person
who stole
his phone ended up going into the app
actually first of all
they said that they were going to be
returning the phone so he was like okay
cool
you found my phone awesome and
because of that reason he also didn't
have access internet access for
24 hours after losing it so he wasn't
able to block his sim card
or do anything significant to prevent
his phone from
further getting hacked or whatever and
so and that time that they told the
hackers told him that
he was going to be getting his phone
back they were actually lying and
buying time in order to get this this
loan out and the amount was for 20 000
it was 1.5 million rubles but that's a
lot of rubles you can just request a
loan in an app
that's the thing that the victim is like
[ __ ] you bank
why is it so easy to get a [ __ ]
twenty thousand signed [ __ ]
yeah i wish it was easy to get a loan
over here well the thing is they managed
to withdraw
140 000 rubles which is about 1 900
to their accounts before the bank
blocked the transfers
and so for that amount of money 1 900
the bank is coming after the victim and
saying well you're responsible for this
loan
it was in your name you didn't block
your sim card
you didn't report your phone stolen fast
enough it's your fault
damn and so now he has to pay interest
on it
and so they're saying the phone don't
have a face id
or something like that i was thinking no
no
sorry really quick the thing that the
way that they were able to
verify is by giving an electronic
signature which that signature is the
bank
texting a code to the phone which they
had that's some
[ __ ] oh no because i was thinking i
was thinking about the face id thing and
i was like what would i
how would i crack a phone i'm like i
wonder if this would work
weapon bank of russia is just saying
words i was thinking if i
i was like that's the most joe thing
ever i found a phone and i want to get
into an app and it had the face id i
wonder if it would work if i took the
phone
people probably have selfies on there so
i send a selfie
of the owner's picture to my phone it's
gonna go on like a depth thing though
it does for the iphone it has this depth
it does that it's not just a picture of
you
same with like instagram filters you
know how like it like morphs like you
know how you see the line sometimes
because they're actually going in like
the depth
of your face hopefully he has a oh he
doesn't have an iphone maybe
and then i'm trying to understand more
verification processes to pull a 20 000
loan and then even if you get approved
for a 20 000 loan
or uh whatever the rules is they only
give you increments at a time before
that was weird to me too
i was like why wasn't the whole thing
they just the only way that they
explained it is
they managed to withdraw transfer money
like in the movies where it's like can
you see the bar
ten thousand two twenty thousand three
thousand it's like yeah yeah
just come on come on come on come on
give me the money it can make sense yeah
well the only thing i can see is uh
maybe they're
applying for a bank account process is
more stringent than ours so maybe
there's like
a lot of information that could provide
up front so that this loan process could
be easier
that is something to point out really
quick that they did mention that it was
a pre-approved loan
uh oh i see yeah so it's his fault that
his credit is already so good
that any loan would have just got proved
anyways and then for the bank to be like
no you just have to pay it back
i can kind of see it from the bank's
point of view because it's been such a
long period of time like 24 hours i
think is
what she mentioned what if she was in
the mountains true true i know but but
like as a bank you have to he was
wrestling a bear you have to right
training um yeah as a bank you have to
protect like your [ __ ] too and you you
know how many people are trying to like
hack the system so maybe for them
they're like nah this looks fishy
already you know but over here don't our
banks
and like have like insurance so if there
is fraud at the end of the day they can
get them investigate from insurance
yeah they can't investigate like they're
refusing to even
investigate at all like nothing and so
so the whole thing here is that they
the the bank wants him to pay the loan
back and also the interest and to point
out
he's he was saying that the loan
interest is very high if within five
years you pay off a loan of 1.5 million
rubles and the interest alone is
300 000 which is about four thousand
dollars
so he has to pay that's a lot of money
he has to pay
he can't just make a police report call
the kgb
well that's the thing to the bank
they're saying
this wasn't fast enough there's a
hotline it wasn't fast enough
well what if he was he was [ __ ] tied
up
and they're like sorry buddy you're not
fast enough [ __ ] i was in the chair
tied up like this with things around my
mouth you should have said something
make sure it didn't happen i know right
picture no the guy had my phone i can't
take it
no yeah so so a member of the moscow
lawyers board says
i was thinking more of a sports team
like the moscow meatballs
what is it with you in a meatball i like
meatballs meatballs and meatloaf i don't
know
i do like meat yeah but yeah so
i was i thought you didn't say balls but
that worked too
anyway what i was trying to say was um
that this
member of the moscow lawyers board said
if the bank
was not notified in advance in fact the
risk of adverse consequences can easily
can be easily assigned by the court to
the victim
yucky it doesn't make sense though
really it makes sense it's not a
fortunate thing but it makes sense right
like if i was the bank
and i had no idea what's going on and if
you were pre-approved and you are
willingly and accepted to using
a digitized app in order to manage your
funds you assume risk
yeah right it's like and then it's like
if whatever verification code security
breach what
like as a bank i have no idea but
if i wanted you to stay as a customer
then i might have a fraud protection
program or concept in place or an
insurance thing that could protect from
homes like this
so like technically i don't blame the
bank but then i also would think this
guy would be a fool to keep banking with
that bank yeah you gotta leave bank of
putin
yeah alpha get out of there called alpha
bank alpha bank
go to beta oh that that's us go to bank
of putin then
[ __ ] jp putin chase
chase is already the last name i was
listening to this one podcast
and uh and it just blew my mind how like
different countries operate differently
yeah they got a lot of corruption
yeah so like this our banks this one
happened here right but so there's this
guy who's traveling with the kettlebell
to india and because this is part of his
thing
and then so when he got to the airport
the indian like i guess tsa was like
hey just put the kettlebell just stuff
it in that guy's luggage is someone
open up someone else's luggage put it in
the blue duffel bag and then he's like
wait you want me to put in the
stranger's duffel bag because yeah just
put there and then
when you land you just pull it out of it
what then i was just like
what the [ __ ] different people like
different countries literally have
different
ways of just thinking about stuff and
like handling things
i'm like that is just crazy so did he do
it what happened
i don't know if he did or not but he was
just telling the story of like can you
imagine being the guy with a duffel bag
you pick it up you're like what the [ __ ]
why because it's so
heavy and then you're like yoo-hoo
that's mine sorry
she said yoo-hoo
yeah yeah they said when he was in japan
like they're like oh
you don't bring it on a plane like this
is not packaged so they pat the lady the
flight attendant
really nicely even put a handle on top
of it and
she carried it in heels like running a
hundred yards
while sweating profusely kettlebell wait
why is this his thing why does he why
does he have
to bring kettlebells on the plane start
so it's a long story but he's the guy
that started spartan race
and on one of the guys that he first was
was coaching
to motivate the person because he was
like 600 pounds he was letting him know
that
for every pound that you lose i will
carry that with my life oh that's cute
so that we can transfer your weight to
me
and so that became a thing so now he's
like wherever he goes he carry
has to carry 600 pounds this is well
it's like 45 pounds out but that's his
thing where he goes wherever he goes he
carries it forever
i don't know i think he just became a
sting it just warmed my heart does he
have multiple clients he has to carry
off
he's like all my clients i don't know
he's just walking with the barbell that
blue duffle bag has held the kettlebells
dude
i don't know i know the fact that they
picked a duffel bag is what kills me
because i'm like you could have easily
gotten a roller made it easier like for
the
to pick the stranger bag what if the bag
was like filled with like electronics or
something like valuable you just drop it
on there different countries just
do things in different ways it's just
crazy yeah other countries just steal
your things
yeah as you're leaving the country i
talked about turkey
morocco oh yeah they stole our or what
happens at lax
you talk about they took my drugs last
time
you know they took my bullets i was
really mad
i mean you didn't know you hadn't under
bullets though they said that would you
like to put it on your
um your chicken chicken and i was like
i'm going to australia no thank you and
i let them have my bullets
the difference though between carry on
and check in is is pretty vast so like i
uh accidentally totally accidentally had
a pocket knife that was left in one of
my backpacks i just felt like moving or
something like that and i had a pocket
knife in my backpack i was going home
from singapore
and i was the last one was getting on
the plane with the other kind just
everybody made it on and they stopped me
but that's singapore though that's the
worst place to be caught with a knife
but they were so nice about it because
because they're like oh he's a stupid
american
like like four or five militarized
people came over like full machine guns
like everything and it was just like
i didn't even know what was going on
then they like checked the bag pull out
the knife
like yo like first of all it's a really
really kind of uh gaudy knife because
it's like the cheapest rated gold one on
amazon was like 12 bucks highest rated
and i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna open
my box with a gold knife
anyways got this thing it looks really
intense because you know how to do that
and i'm trying to explain i'm like yo
like i know it looks crazy but it's the
cheapest highest rated on amazon
right and then the entire time they were
just like they had to file this huge
report it was a huge thing they believed
that i wasn't a dangerous person but it
was a huge deal
and then the lady the flight attendant
lady was like
do you think we could put it in his
checking was she like all nervous and
shaking she was kind of cool just
literally the last i was the last person
so they needed a plane to go and they
had to follow this whole report or keep
him back and he was like can we put in
his check-in
and the security guy is like if his
check-in is still here and they can stop
it yeah just put in the check-in
and i'm like just keep it i could be a
murderous person but like that's all it
takes you don't understand
so they they radio the person who's
putting the bags in they pull the bring
the bag all the way up
they put the knife in the check-in and
they're like you're good to go
didn't follow you went into singapore
with this one
i somehow made it in singapore i no no
throwing it away is actually a problem
if if you if i have to uh i guess
whatever the
idea of the jurisdiction is in that in
that way or the legalities is if i have
that knife and i choose to throw it away
it's like almost like assuming
responsibility like it is mine in that
way
because someone takes it and stabs
someone sure then you're in trouble too
yeah
but like they're like if we keep it we
have to file a whole report
but like if you keep it legally then you
could just go right now so you could
have kept it in your
check-in yeah but it was in my carry-on
so yeah they don't like the carry-on
because then you can pull it out and
[ __ ] think
it makes a lot of sense it's just crazy
to think like that's how like the rules
can be
just you know yeah well a lot of
countries that allow firearms you can
check in your firearms because people
travel and they hunt
and then they need to go and they like
their own little get up you know
so that makes sense
[Music]
you